نعم ليلى نحن نتحدث عن اقتراب دخول الشهر
الخامس لهذه المعارك لا تزال احياء شمال
غزه محور عمليات رئيسي رغم اعلانات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن الانسحاب من
المناطق الشماليه من قطاع غزه وهي المناطق
التي بدات فيها العمليه البريه
الاسرائيليه في ال 27 من اكتوبر في نهايه
شهر اكتوبر وبعد ذلك بشهرين تقريبا اعلن
الاحتلال انسحابه من هذه المناطق والتحول
للمرحله الثانيه والمرحله الثالثه من
العمليه البريه ولكن خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه ال 24 ساعه الماضيه كان هناك 11
اعلانا من كتائب القسام وحدها عن
استهدافات لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
المناطق الشماليه من مدينه غزه وبالتحديد
في منطقتي حيي التفاح والدرج في منطقه
جباليا البلد وفي منطقه الشيخ عجلين في
هذه المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه
غزه اذا زل نتحدث عن توغلات وان كانت هذه
التوغ محدوده للقوات الاسرائيليه
المتواجده بطبيعه الحال في في المناطق
الشرقيه من مدينه غزه من من جهه بيت حنون
رغم الانسحاب الكبير الذي نفذته قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال الايام
والاسابيع القليله الماضيه من المناطق
الشماليه من قطاع غزه من المناطق الشرقيه
من عند الشجاعيه تل الزعتر وشرقي التفاح
والدرج ومن المناطق الشماليه الغربيه من
منطقه الصفطاوي ومخيم الشاطئ والشيخ رضوان
وتتمركز القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
المنطقه الجنوبيه منطقه جحر الديك
والزيتون في المنطقه الجنوبيه من مدينه
غزه ولكن قوات الاحتلال لا تزال تنفذ
عمليات يبدو انها عمليات مباغته لدخول
واقتحامات محدده في عده مناطق ترد عليها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه باستهداف القوات
الراجله والاليات العسكريه المتوغلة
الشيخ عجلين في المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
اذا رغم حديث الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على انه
وحديث وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي على انه
هناك بعض جيوب للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في
قطاع غزه الا اننا نتحدث الان عن ضربات لا
تزال قادره المقاومه الفلسطينيه على
القيام بها في المناطق الشماليه رغم القصف
العنيف الذي تعرضت له هذه المناطق والمكوث
الطويل للقوات البريه في المنطقه الشماليه
من قطاع غزه اذا ما تحدثنا الى المنطقه
الوسطى من قطاع غزه فنحن نتحدث عن ايضا
استهدافات لقوات الاحتلال المتوغلة
الكبير الذي تعرضت له هذه المنطقه من
الجهه الشرقيه الشماليه الشرقيه الشماليه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه يعجز الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عن اقتحام واختراق خان يونس
ويتعرض لقصف عنيف وعمليات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وتحديدا كتابه القسام في
المنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه خان يونس هذه
التحلي هذه المعلومات